[Music]
this week being a plenary week
in the european parliament the college
meeting will
take place tomorrow afternoon
the college will discuss the following
points ahead of
thursday's video conference of the
members of the european
council the college will adopt a
communication on the situation
regarding kovid 19 in europe
and furthermore commissioners will also
adopt a communication on the european
economic and financial system
fostering openness strength and
resilience
on this second subject we will offer you
a technical briefing
under embargo tomorrow afternoon at 2 pm
on this and further press arrangements
will be
communicated to you later
now i would like to pass the floor to
vivian who has good news
on cohesion policy
good afternoon the european commission
has approved a project worth of 60
million euros
from the cohesion fund for portugal this
will allow to convert an old railway
line
into a route for electric buses
connecting coimbra
with its neighboring municipalities this
new line will make it easier for people
to travel
it will reduce congestion and traffic
related noise as well as
carbon and greenhouse gas emissions
and as usual you will find more
information on our
you funded investments on the open data
platform as well as in today's daily
news
thank you short
[Music]
foreign
questions
[Music]
can you hear me hello
yes we can hear you yes we can hear you
thank you thank you very much and uh
happy new year
first to you all my question is on
uh minority safe pack why has the
european commission rejected the
minority safe pack initiative
these citizens initiative had been
supported by
more than one million signatures by
european citizens
three quarters of european parliament
almost 600
maps and several national parliaments
including the german
bundestag supported the initiative and
previously the european court of justice
also ruled that
measures could be adopted on this
subject so
why is the european commission not
initiating legislation when protection
of the rights of minorities
linguistics and culture and diversity is
a fundamental value of the
union in accordance with articles
too and my second uh question on
defending on minority
rights uh six months after the black
lives matter movement the commission has
drawn up uh
an anti-racism action plan and the
commission already has a gender strategy
so why cannot the commission have a
strategy on
european ethnic minorities thank you so
much thank you very much
thank you very much catalin and i pass
the floor to christian
yes thank you for your question catalin
and also happy new year
um let me let me say the following the
college
agreed last week indeed on the
commission reply to the european
citizens
initiative minority safe pack which is
actually the fifth
successful initiative by supported by
over one million
citizens across the eu
the reply carefully assesses each of the
nine individual proposals
setting out how existing and recently
adopted
eu legislation supports the different
aspects of this initiative
so let me make clear that the college
did of course not reject
the citizens initiative but we agreed
that
the full implementation of legislation
and policies
already in place provides a tower
powerful toolbox
to support the initiatives goals which
are indeed
very important um i'll
answer your whole i think your two
questions in one but i'll give you a
number of
of elements to explain a little bit in
more detail our position
which you will also find if you if you
read the
initiative or the response to the
initiative
itself so first of all in more general
terms
on european citizens initiatives
as i mentioned we had already five
successful
citizens initiatives in the meantime and
um to two of them uh the commission
only quite recently actually um answered
with
uh also with legislative proposals for
instance on
ban glyphosate and toxic pesticides
where the new regulation was formerly
adopted
in june last year and will become
applicable in march this year
and in the right to water initiative
where the commission proposed the
revision of the drinking water directive
which actually just
entered into force a few days ago on the
12th of january
and then there's another initiative stop
review section where the commission
responded with other actions with
non-legislative actions and
the so-called one of us initiatives for
the commission did not submit the
legislative proposal
um given that we considered that the eu
framework in place is adequate so more
concretely
on on this initiative now
let's not forget that the initiative
goes back to
the year 2013. so it's quite a few years
ago
that all these that this initiative was
launched and the different different
proposals
were put on the table and of course in
the meantime
time didn't stop so there was a lot
ongoing
on the european level in terms of
initiatives
that were also uh supporting if i may
say the the spirit
of uh of a lot of these proposals that
were put in there
um and i would just like to give you a
few examples to make it
a bit concrete so for instance
the initiative is calling for a council
recommendation to further
protect and promote cultural and
linguistic diversity
so in the last few years we had three
council recommendations one in 2018 one
in 2019
and one in 2020 that addressed exactly
such issues of more cultural and
linguistic
diversity or a second
um example that i would like to give to
you is this
a center for linguistic diversity um
if you look a bit closer you will see
that there is already a council of
europe
european center for modern languages for
which the commission
provides also financial support so you
also have to look into issues like
avoiding uh duplication of efforts and
and saving
resources and the third and last
uh example that i would like to give is
uh about the issue of um of copyright
which was uh mentioned which is i think
is very well known to most journalists
following this year from the heated
debates in the last years about it and
as you know we had quite
some changes in copyright legislation
very recently that were now agreed
um so also here um time has moved on
in a sense but this does not mean that
we
do not support a lot of the important
goals of these initiatives and that we
will continue
monitoring how these different measures
that are in place
are being implemented by the member
states thank you
thank you christian i believe there are
other questions on this issue i would
ask all the colleagues who have raised
their hands
who are not going to ask a question on
this
to unraise your hands please and i give
the floor
to tebow
hello can you hear me yes t-ball go
ahead
the commission uh announced last
december
that from this year there will be an
annual report on the implementation of
the charter of the fundamental rights
which will look into how member states
apply the charter in
a selected thematic area
my question is if there is already a
plan
which thematic areas will be covered and
if the situation of national minorities
to come back to this topic
will be examined independent of other
minorities due to their
special problems thank you
christian yes thank you for your
question tibor
indeed that is correct it was announced
in our fundamental rights strategies
that we would come forward
with such dramatic reports on
fundamental rights and i can actually
confirm already that the rights of
minorities
will indeed be covered in one of these
forthcoming reports
thank you you are there other questions
for christian today
samuel
we bonjour confederation
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
we
[Music]
um
catherine rule of law question for
christianity
uh eric it's um
for christian it go ahead can i continue
if it's for christians
okay it's not a christian
so sorry again you were
not first in the queue holidays and we
have a
i can hear myself in your mic in your in
your loudspeakers
um so i go back to oliver
oliver you have the floor
hi hello uh yeah on the virus uh on
traveling and so forth
um uh can you tell us which members of
the commission
college took part in the trip to
portugal uh
who of them had contact with the
portuguese finance
minister i would assume all of them
because i guess they were all in
a conference room together the one who
actually tested positive the day after
the travel
thirdly i think belgian law requires
them to go into a quarantine for
for 14 days now can you confirm how they
tend
how they intend to deal with uh
quarantine and testing requirements
and finally on a more political level in
light of this
confirmed infection of of the portuguese
minister during this meeting and so
forth
do you still think it was a wise choice
for almost half of the commission
college to travel
to lisbon in person instead of doing
that via remotely organized conference
thank you
thank you oliver uh so to answer your
questions
uh the delegation which traveled to
lisbon comprise the president as you
know the three executive
vice presidents the high representative
vice president mr bohel vice president
skinas vice president sefkovic
and commissioners faire reinschmidt so
we are far away from half of the college
as uh you say it is rather one-third
of the college that traveled um
the commissioners that are considered
contact persons according to
the way the meetings were held and the
analysis
done both by the portuguese authorities
and ourselves
are the three and which we have
mentioned
these these last days so
vice president executive vice president
mrs
vestager executive vice president mr
dombrowskis
and commissioner ferreira and they are
in self-isolation they will be tested
according to uh the belgian rules
as they currently stand on the seventh
day after coming back
and then uh the uh the
quarantine sorry i said self-isolation
they are quarantined i understand we are
supposed to say
and then um it will depend obviously on
the
um on the result of the of the test
as to uh whether it is a good it was a
good idea in hindsight
to go on the mission or not well what i
can say is that
of course these decisions are not taken
lightly
the president reflected
on this but it is considered
an essential mission because it is the
launch of an extremely
important presidency there are many many
files which need to be carried forward
by
the portuguese presidency and it was
felt
important to be able to hold
in-person discussions on
these different political files you're
not without knowing that
here in brussels there are differences
um for example
there are vtc's video conferences sorry
i should say
of of leaders there will be one this
week but
on certain other files uh leaders do
meet
in brussels so it depends on the
importance of the uh
of the event so of course we
try to take all the precautions that are
necessary
but yes the meeting was considered
sufficiently
essential for this reduced delegation to
travel
to lisbon
are there other questions on this
issue please only keep your hand raised
if it is
on the mission to lisbon
mosey you have a question on this
question but more importantly i think on
the virus
and the vaccination process now if i may
okay especially as you said in the
announcement that the issue of the
recognition will be discussed
this week today at european affairs
minister's
meeting also later by the council
so my question would be first one
question whether
the distribution and allocation of the
vaccine doses by member states
we know that it's supposed to be on the
basis of pro letter um
on the numbers of the population member
states but we also know that they are
differing
different let's say
vaccination reluctancies in the member
states
in italy i think perhaps only 60
now 40 percent four percent or against
vaccination in
in france up to 60 even according to
reports in the media i wonder if
this somehow will influence or modify
the allocation of the
vaccine those system member states and
another for love question is there
which i've tried to figure out also
directly
to hear me yes yes we hear you
yeah thank you from european vaccines
vaccines agency emma without success
that is
what is the recommendation for the two
different vaccinations to be taken
with the fisa vaccine according to the
website there should be at least
21 days from between the first and the
second
shot but it seems not to be clear how
long that interval can be
and i think very important to know i
mean how long can we
wait uh with taking a second shot
because in some countries worked up in
sweden my own home country
i hear that okay they can wait for four
weeks
but i don't think that is what pfizer
itself has recommended
so what does the commission know about
this very important issue
thank you thank you moses these are
questions both questions are for stefan
i pass him the floor
hello moses good afternoon on the first
question with regard
to the distribution of vaccines you know
indeed as you stressed yourself
that these vaccines are distributed on
the base of the pro rata distribution
key
we look at the population that's always
the starting point for the distribution
of all these vaccines
of course member states as we have
explained already
in the press room as well have the
possibility to discuss between
themselves
to possibly agree on a redistribution of
doses on the basis of needs
new needs that member states may have
some member states may wish less of a
certain vaccine
other member states may wish more of a
certain vaccine so in the context of
such discussion it's these discussions
it is possible to agree on a
redistribution which goes beyond
the starting point which is the pro-rata
distribution
that's the first point on the second
point with regards to
emma and the number of days between the
two doses of pfizer
you are right to say that emma is the
organization that is following this so
they are the people that can give you
the the right scientific advice on this
maybe
um so so i definitely refer you to them
what i could say however is that
um the use of the vexis has to happen in
line with the product
information of the vaccine that the
product
that the developer that the company has
not provided any evidence
regarding extending the uh
the administration of the second dose
which would lead to
immunization of the the
patient or the the person who has been
administered the vaccine
so we basically have to look at the
scientific
evidence which is there but as far as
this scientific evidence is concerned
emma is obviously much better
qualified than me to give you the
information thank you
thank you let's stick to the issue of
vaccines
thomas
uh yes it's up to me well it's not
vaccines but it is on the journey to
portugal which was the subject that we
would stick to
before this is
okay great um uh so on
on the subject if this journey was
essential i can imagine that you think
it was essential but on thursday there
was apparently another essential meeting
of commissioners
in brussels a lot of commissioners were
in their home countries just before that
tomorrow we will have yet another
essential meeting of the commissioners
in brussels again
um i think there are a lot of companies
in europe who are
not doing these kind of meetings at the
moment and who are not judging these
meetings
uh essential can you explain why all
these meetings are still
uh going on uh within the european
commission
well clearly because the uh the business
that the college has um in uh managing
the crisis and and continuing the work
on its program on its priorities
is extremely extremely important and as
you know
this has been going on now for uh for
quite some time these meetings have been
taking place without any adverse effects
for the very simple reason that the
college is taking all the necessary
protective measures and social
distancing measures in order for those
meetings
to to take place in safe conditions
it is only a very small minority of
meetings
in the in the commission that are taking
place physically essentially
uh the meeting of the college of um of
commissioners
and um also the meeting of heads of
cabinet but also
in a very streamlined format
most of the other activities of the
commission are taking place
and are taking place remotely and i
think that to consider that the meeting
of the college of commissioners
is essential and goes goes without
saying it's
it is absolutely essential for
commissioners to be able to discuss
the files they do so in person except
those who for one reason
or another are in quarantine or
self-isolation who take place
remotely
david i believe your question is on the
same subject
thanks thanks very much eric um not to
not to belabor the the point here but um
if you could perhaps comment on the fact
that
this is not just a question of the
commission assessing that this was
essential business but that it was
essential business and essential travel
to a member state that is experiencing
one of the worst covid situations at the
moment
and i wonder if in particular you can
you can talk to us about two things one
is that we understand from
the cabinet of vice president vestager
that she's in self-isolation because she
was sitting
at dinner with the portuguese finance
minister
and you had assured us that all the
social distancing measures would be
taken before this trip
and the question is whether the
commission is sufficiently adapting
even in the case of essential business
its
working methods was a dinner in fact
essential to be sitting eating
prolonging the business as opposed to
getting the meetings done
as quickly and with as much socially
social distancing
as possible and then beyond this
question of course it's about
the for the message to the citizens of
europe about whether in fact the
commission
is making the kinds of sacrifices that
individual citizens are also being asked
to make
knowing that the business of the
commission is essential but the launch
of the presidency is not the business of
the presidency and finally if you could
just talk to us about what plans if any
are in place
for vaccinating if this kind of travel
is going to continue
does the commission have a plan to
vaccinate the president the
the vice presidents and the full college
so that they can continue this business
without
repeated risks and again disruptions
that come from then having to
self-isolate
because some of us of course it asks you
about this sensing it was inevitable
that an incident like this would occur
thanks so much
wow well that was a mouthful
requires a lot of attention to follow
but thank you first of all for
your concern for the health of
commissioners
and trust me you know i heard you
pronounce the word privilege um i find
it
quite amazing to believe that us
traveling to lisbon
for a day of meetings from basically
eight o'clock in the morning until one
o'clock at night
is a privilege and that the people who
have to go to work every day as many
people do on the front line
to man shops or do all the other things
that
people are doing are privileged because
they get to go
they get to go to work the fact is that
it was considered important to have
one-on-one
discussions with the ministers who will
be
running the presidency in a period that
is absolutely
essential let me remind you for example
that we
are trying to ensure that
the next generation eu and mff
can can start
their operations as quickly as possible
we need to ensure that we can continue
to work together
on all the health related files and so
on and
and so on in terms of the precautions
taken well obviously
the college took all the precautions
that it could
and then of course once we are in
portugal and
we are in the hands of the portuguese
presidency who also took
all the precautions uh that that they
could but nevertheless
in view of the circumstances it was
considered
that these three members of the college
would be considered
contact um contact persons
um then in terms of
um the vaccination of commissioners i
believe we have already answered
that question we will be uh
implementing the policy um in line
with uh belgian rules and this is
currently being
being assessed and developed so we will
come back to you
on that at a at a later point in time
other questions on this jack
hello yes go ahead jack can you hear me
thank you that was an interesting uh
comment about privilege because
normally public servants do sort of feel
it's a privilege to
to serve their their populations but um
my question is
are we going to stop this kind of travel
now considering it's causing you know so
so much issues with with people having
to quarantine and stuff when they get
back thank you the comment on the
privilege was not about serving the
european people which is definitely
a very very big privilege which we feel
every day it was about the fact of
going on mission um to lisbon to hold
meetings only that very specific point
um on trips um i think
it's very clear that we take decisions
on a case-by-case basis depending on the
circumstances and the contacts with our
partners let me remind you that in this
case
we went to lisbon at the invitation of
the portuguese presidency who maintained
the invitation
and therefore we will have to see what
are the next
meetings that are up on the agenda and
under which circumstances they take
place and whether it will be considered
essential that they take place or not
i think that the president felt that
these meetings were extremely helpful
and so did the other members of the um
of the college um and that they will
therefore play a positive role
in moving forward our agenda
in this first half of the year
other questions on this or on health
related matters
and i have sando sunder
jack you have a follow-up sorry i seem
to have missed it
hello sorry my question is what is the
criteria for an essential meeting then
if if we when you get invited to other
meetings
what decides whether it's an essential
meeting or a non-essential meeting
thank you it's um it's a decision which
the commission
is allowed to take on a case-by-case
basis there are no formal criteria
set out for this the international
institutions present in belgium
are allowed to decide um what they
consider
to be the essential business that they
need to carry out
in person and therefore the college
assesses this
based on the individual circumstances of
the meeting
that is supposed to take place and again
um it was felt
that um having one-on-one discussions
in portugal was in the current
circumstances
essential
so we move on to the next question
sandra
i messed up my audio settings so i hope
i you can hear me
and it seems you do to push you a little
bit further on this
point because you gave a formalistic
response
um we can do certain things and we
assess if we
stay within those limits now you can
also imagine that as a
eu institution you fulfill the role of a
role model
so to all those businesses that think
okay
my travel is essential as well and i can
have dinner if i want to as well
is this the right signal you send
especially since you
have seen a rise of covet infections
in the brussels city of eterbeg of close
to 100 percent
after christmas holiday so what is the
public signal you send by
sticking to this formalistic line
i don't think at all it is a formalistic
line i think that it is
a decision which was taken
based on the circumstances the political
circumstances
that we are in the
management of public policies
in europe is a very specific business
and once again these are not decisions
which are taken lightly and let me
remind you that
almost all of the commission's business
is currently taking place online almost
all of it there are very limited
exceptions and they are of a very
political nature
and this is the nature of the business
that the college had to carry out in um
in portugal so yes the message which is
being sent
to citizens is that the european
commission tries
as much as it can to carry out its
business um
and so do we hear for example in the
press room virtually
there are very limited exceptions when
it seems
when it is our um when it is our
assessment
that there are clear political
advantages in order to
implement the policies that um that we
are designing
and implementing to meet um in person
and this is what
led us to carry out this one day mission
to portugal at the invitation let me
remind you of
the portuguese authorities
thanks eric it's not about the trip to
lisbon it's
about comments that the president
made ahead of the trip and also in 11
regarding this idea of the
vaccination passport the
president mentioned that there was there
would be a political debate and also a
legal debate so my question is
does the commission have any sort of
legal assessment
of this proposal and if so can we
know what it says thanks
thank you rita i think she meant that um
there were
legal rights that um uh
you know were being mentioned
potentially um
as um as existing for those who would
have such a passport or not and that it
was extremely important
to determine um what would be
uh the uh the the potential rights or
not of people and that this was a very
delicate debate
that needed to be to be had
and that indeed an occasion to discuss
this
would come during the meeting of the
heads of state and government that would
take place
on thursday here by vtc
yes good morning thank you for the floor
it's just two questions from vaccines if
i may the first one
is because i've read that uh buyer has
is in talks with the curvac to join
forces
to produce the upcoming vaccine against
covet 19
and there is a trend i see in the
european industry
to join forces to build up
the production capacity which is
necessary to
increase the production of vaccines i
wonder if the european commission is
applying
some sort of pressure on the private
industry to accelerate this trend
which might be helpful to overcome the
current predicament and the second one
is on the contracts i know are covered
by
commercial secrets the confidentiality
and so on
but i just wonder if you can tell us if
they foresee the possibility for the
member states to
impose fines or some kind of
penalization for companies
which do not respect the i mean
the calendar the schedule of the
deliveries of the vaccines thank you
thank you stephan
uh thank you very much thomas on your
first question regarding the talks
between bayer and curvac um
uh of course we're not going to
pronounce ourselves on steps that are
taken
by private companies in this or in that
sense the only thing
which which i would like to stress is
that it's important that in the european
union
we ensure a good production capacity of
the vaccines you know that
production capacity is one of the main
challenges that we have to face
to have a quick production of the many
vaccines that we need
and initiatives that help to ensure more
production capacity
are of course more than welcome with
regard to the to the contract
i will not uh go into details of what
contracts say or not with regard to late
or
not late deliveries we have contracts
with
several types of clauses contracts um
one of these contracts in particular the
cure contract has been made available in
a reading room for the member
for members of the european parliament
but i will not go
into the the question as to which type
of clauses we have in the different
contracts thank you stephanie if i can
ask you
switch off your mobile phone thanks
or to put it on mute oliver question on
another question
on vaccines
um hi hello
yes you're back on screen i don't know
i'm not sure you'll see me but anyway
uh um david's question on
the on the dinner i think is still open
whether that was a good idea and whether
you
the commissioners could simply have
other members of the commission simply
said
no we don't want to join there because
it's not safe
and related to the whole vaccination
passport debate
can you give us an update where we are
with the passenger locator form i asked
about this two weeks ago and
got the reply that basically there's no
no no major progress so far
but if you want to have a serious debate
about
a vaccination certificate you will at
least have to figure out the passenger
locator form because you need databases
of people who are
moving across borders and these
databases need to be able to talk with
each other and so forth
so where are we with with the plf
as it is called in brussels jargon thank
you
thank you very much on the dinner i
think that i answered this
in the context of my general response
on the necessity to have
discussions with the portuguese
ministers
on how to on how to move forward
on the portuguese presidency agenda
those dinners
were part of that of that meeting
and therefore they took place in that in
that context
on your question related to plf i passed
the floor to stefan
yes hello thank you for this question
and thank you oliver to to remind us of
this
important file of the passenger locator
form um
the what i can tell you is that european
aviation safety agency
has been working with several member
states to develop indeed a
technical platform um for this passenger
locator form this platform is ready
ready to be used and it's now up to the
member states to make sure that the
necessary illegal document
documents are in place which allow the
member states to share
data with them but the work has been
done by european
aviation safety agency and so now
member states have to do the necessary
steps to
be connected and allow shang of data
thank you
thank you atanasius you have your hand
raised so a question on vaccines i
presume
that's right thank you i'll get back to
this uh
vaccination certificate and i was
wondering if
the greek side did provide any uh
scientific evidence
that uh those who are vaccinated cannot
transmit the virus which the whole
purpose of
taking precautionary measurable travel
is
to avoid people getting contaminated so
did they provide any such scientific
data or do you have other sources that
with complete certainty tell you that
those who are vaccinated cannot transmit
the virus thanks
stefan
yes thank you
there is not yet uh it's not yet known
to what extent people that have been
vaccinated properly
can no longer transmit uh the uh the the
the disease so we have to be very
careful here this being said
i believe this is a question that has to
be uh
checked by our colleagues from the
european medicine agency which is
following these issues from a very
medical scientific point of view of
course thank you
thank you stefan davis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
exceptional
um
[Music]
[Music]
hi good afternoon my question is related
to the
include the arrest of alexey nagali
and is there any sign that
the high representative will propose
sanctions uh to include some
some persons in the residently adopted
new
sanction regime in connection with the
arrest of mr navalny yesterday
thank you peter hi mom chill thank you
maybe first um allow me to recall that
there was a strong
european condemnation of the arrest of
mr navalny uh when he came back to
moscow yesterday the eu um the
representatives of the eu the president
of the commission the president of the
european council the high representative
are very clear that we are calling for
immediate release of mr navarny and that
the
politicization of the judiciary
uh and the detention of political
opponents is unacceptable and it goes
contrary to
russia's international obligations so
this really needs to stop
and we also call upon russian
authorities to release from detention
also the number of journalists and
people who came to the airport to
to show their support for mr navalny um
on your question
uh apart from the reactions you have
seen the public you can assume that
there is a lot of discussions uh
currently among the member states uh
how to follow up on these very
unfortunate events
and i can only say that the process of
invoking or suggesting and drafting the
sanctions and the restrictive measures
is of course a confidential process that
is not conducted in the public
so once the decision has been made and
decision adopted you know that it
requires
unanimous um agreement of the member
state
then it's uh communicated uh in an
appropriate way
at this stage the discussions are
ongoing among the member states
about what would be the best and most
efficient follow-up
to these very unfortunate events
thank you other questions on this case
for peter catherine
is it on this it's nice yes it is eric
thank you very much so um
peter you know you say that you can't
really openly discuss
you know who you might be considering
for that list
but uh alexia navalny was very very
clear
when he addressed the european
parliament recently
and he said there was no point in
sanctioning certain people you had to
sanction
putin's inner circle and you had to
follow the money and he
he mentioned some people whose manual
vertebrae
abramovic the people who um who have
gained
from this particular regime and uh and
i'm just wondering um
you know given that he is the victim um
that we are aware that the sanctions
would be directed at helping
i mean shouldn't you listen to his uh
counsel on this and target the money
well maybe i would touch upon first on
one aspect which you mentioned and
that's the fact that
mr naval is a russian citizen who was uh
poisoned
on russian soil there was an attempt to
kill him on a russian soil
with a prohibited chemical agent this is
very serious and that's why we are
expecting from the russian authorities
really to investigate this fully in and
transparent way
and cooperate also fully with the
organization for prohibition of chemical
weapons the opcw because it's very
important
to investigate this in this connection
we really expect and call upon
russian authorities to protect and
respect the rights of mr navalny as a
russian citizen
and when it comes to sanctions of course
the member states take into account a
lot of
input that is coming when they are
suggesting and discussing
the procedure whom or which subjects or
which entities
and which individuals to put on the
sanctions list so
they take into account everything at
their disposal to prepare
the sanctions list in the way that it
has sound legal basis because this is
clear legal act
and needs to be uh justified based on
legal grounds
and they proceed then based on the best
best
knowledge or best best state of the of
the information they have
when they do the listings but again this
is a process that takes place in
confidentiality
and uh there's no point in trying to
discuss the partial
elements of this process in the public
catheter you have a follow-up
yes eric um you say that the russian
authorities are
should investigate this but as uh
navalny also pointed out to the european
parliament
the the eu should be treating
the current russian government as
criminals who have temporarily taken
over power
and we know that these uh killings using
novochok
go well beyond uh russian territory
we've seen it in salisbury
can we trust these authorities and also
the
different investigations by bellingcat
would suggest that the state itself is
very very much
involved in these murders
yes catherine the position of the
european union when it comes to russia
and how we consider the
official representatives of the russian
federation has been captured and
discussed many times most recently in
october last year at the fac
where the ministers have underlined and
reinforced the
there are five guiding principles of the
eu
russia relations currently these guiding
principles have been defined back in
2016 they haven't changed
um it's a complex relationship mr
navalny is an important part
of that relationship but the high
representative boreal was also very
clear at the
press conference after that fac in
october that uh the eu russia relations
cannot be
reduced only on the question of mr
navalny remember that we have also
the situation in ukraine that we have to
deal with russia when it comes to the
full implementation of the minsk accords
so this is all again taken into account
by the member states
whose policies and positions are being
formed
jointly in thorough discussions and the
result of these discussions
is the position of the eu towards the
current russian administration
captured in the five guiding principles
thank you are there other questions on
foreign relations
for peter today
foreign
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes please if i may good morning
everybody
um my question concerns the relationship
to uk
in in the domain of uh defense
and security policy are there any
intentions
have we milestones have we an agenda how
to proceed that is my question thank you
very much
maybe at this stage i would stick only
to to a very short indication that uh
this is a subject of forthcoming
discussions among the eu member states
and the foreign ministers
so stay tuned and uh there will be soon
answers more concrete answers also to
this kind of questions
joe a question on foreign relations
sorry eric it was about the uk um in so
i can ask now or i can wait well i'm
afraid to say
that the uk is now formulations
so you can uh go ahead we just had a
question on the uk
in his group interview the other day
mentioned remaining vigilant sorry
joe can you start
we missed the beginning of your question
of your question no worries am i back
um yes so michelle barnier in his
interview with a group of european
newspapers and publications mentioned
the need to be vigilant about the change
in british standards going forward
in relation to the tca um so recently
we've seen britain
reintroduce on an emergency basis
abandoned pesticides
um we have talk of a singapore um
on thames in singapore of europe uh free
ports and
a kind of getting rid of eu law out of
the british statute book so i just
wanted to know
how are you remaining vigilant at the
moment when the partnership council
isn't in kind of forerunning um have we
got any updates on the partnership
council
um and who at the moment is looking
after watching over britain and what
boris government's
boris johnson's government is doing in
terms of changing
regulations that could one day infect
the level playing field
thank you thanks um
joe well you mentioned a lot of
different things but they are all
you said yourself there's talk of so
these are not at all
concrete decisions which have been taken
by the united kingdom
and as you know first of all we never
comment
on these things inside the european
union we're definitely not going to do
it
for a country that is outside of the
european union
and as you know the agreement that we
have signed with the united kingdom
foresees that we will look um at the
impact
of these decisions on the level playing
field this is uh this is what counts
and therefore we are not at all at a
stage where
any of this talk can be seen as having
an influence on the implementation
of the agreement that we have signed
with the united kingdom
on the partnership council however i
will
ask dan to come back to you bilaterally
on this because we do not have
i do not have yet to specific details
any other questions for us
on foreign affairs that does not seem to
be the case
i open the floor to other questions
i see no other hands raised for us today
we are
extremely disciplined one hour ah
han tsube you're breaking the discipline
of the one hour
midday briefing but go ahead another
issue
sorry for that eric sorry extremely
sorry
maybe i missed the point and then please
accept my
apologies on we had last week
a seminar of the co of the college is
there anything
what you can deliver what you what we
can get as an information of the outcome
um the day before you mentioned there
are three
main subjects the the presidency team
europe and
the delivery of the green deal so
is there anything to expect from it
may but maybe i missed the point and
then please accept my apologies
and my last question would be concerning
competition
and this is the uh the never-ending deal
between fincantieri
and santiago de la atlantique on france
what is now the proceeding what is the
procedure what is the proceeding
i learned in french media there are that
that they have extended now for
until the end of uh january or what is
the eu
the commission's position on that thank
you very much and apologies
no no no need to apologize very
legitimate question in any case i mean
on the college seminar
college seminars are occasions for
opportunities for the members of the
college
once again to carry out political
discussions
on the important uh files
that are on the college's table
and and indeed the college seminar had
the honor of
um receiving
the president of the european parliament
mr sasoli to discuss with him
both the extraordinary year
that has just finished and all the work
that has been done
in very very close partnership with the
european parliament
in order to get through a very
impressive number
of files and secondly to look ahead at
the challenges
for the for the year to come and on the
two other files i cannot
obviously go into the details of what
the college discussed but indeed
the president felt that it was important
at this point in time
to focus on the one hand on the external
dimension
of the eu's action you know as well as i
do that
there are many many close links on
what we do in terms of external policies
and
our internal policies and secondly
on the european green deal it has been
extremely important
for this college to stay focused
on the design definition
and now implementation of the european
green deal
in fact it is the college's
conviction that the european green deal
must be a central element in the
response
to the crisis um and furthermore
2021 is going to be an extremely
important year when it comes out to
the rollout of the european green deal
since as you know
we have a whole series of proposals that
will be forthcoming
um in the first half of the year
um in the in order to implement the fit
for 55
so the reduction by 2030 by 55
of greenhouse gas emissions we also have
other
um other
events to keep in mind such as the
biodiversity conference
which will be coming up so for all these
reasons um
it was felt important for the college to
discuss
these files
on your question on fincantieri i passed
the floor
to ariana
hello i can i hope you can see me and
and hear me thanks for
the question i take the occasion to to
recall a bit where we stand on the case
and then what has happened on this case
in the past
so on the 30th october 2019
the commission has opened an in-depth
investigation into the proposed
acquisition of chantilly
antique by fincantieri at that time we
had raised
serious doubts about the compatibility
of the proposed transaction
with the global market for the
construction of large acres
ships because this would have brought to
the removal of santia de la dante
as an important competitive force in the
market
it's already a very concentrated market
which is characterized by very high
barriers to entry and therefore
considering that chantilly
antique and fincantieri are both global
leaders in this market
their combination could have brought to
a risk of higher prices for customers
and for consumers
less choice and reduced incentives to
innovation
on 13th march 2020 so last year
the in-depth investigations into
investigation into the effects of this
transaction has been suspended
this is due to the fact that the parties
have failed to provide in a timely
manner
important information that the
commission needed for the assessment of
the transaction and that
we had requested from them this missing
information is essential
for us to really analyze the impact of
of the transaction on the market and to
ensure um
that it doesn't lead to effective
competition as i was as i was mentioning
uh and so it does not bring to a
detriment for customers and
consumers let me be clear to this date
the parties have not submitted the
requested information
therefore the investigation remains
suspended
once the missing information will have
been provided from the parties
the merger review will will restart our
procedure will restart
and the deadline for our assessment will
be adjusted
accordingly throughout the process
in line with standard procedures the
parties were given
the opportunity to respond to our
concerns
and as of today the parties did not
submit
the some remedies to address the
commission's concerns
neither during the preliminary
investigation phase nor
by the statutory deadline of the
in-depth investigation phase
so no remedies submitted i hope this
provides a bit uh
a screenshot of the situation
thank you very much ariana i think we're
all going to know this case absolutely
by heart
um in the in the coming weeks
in view of the excellent information you
provide on the state of play of a fire
which is not moving
forward okay
i see no other hands raised for us today
so remember tomorrow college readout we
will specify
subsequently the subject of the press
conference that follows straight from
the college readout
and then we will take up the midday
briefing again on wednesday
thank you very much bon appetit